Reviewed my last ultrasound down to 524 a month or so ago, we discussed the change in the
main mass from 4.0 by 1 pi 7 by 1.2 to 4.5 by 2.6 by 1.4. These were also done in a different
facility by different technicians. Combined with labs and lack of other symptoms, you were very reassuring.
Today, my functional doctor called not a cancer doctor. She's out of her element. She admits
to report that she was told by the radiologist, apparently his main concern was the size of the mass
of the axillary mass which grew from 6 by 3 millimeters last year to 8 millimeters this year.
And I don't know if you know what the other dimension was.
So is this a lot for the lymph node especially considered different machine, different tech?
So if it grew to 8 by 3 or 8 by 5, so it grew 2 millimeters in the course of the year,
is that a lot? No, that's not a lot. So if it so what a lot of growth would be
like a double lead in size in 3 to 6 months. Still, if it doubled in size over 12 months,
I'd still say that's cause for concern. When you're talking a couple millimeter difference,
there's that much room for error on reading. So remember, always that we think of it that your cancer
isn't square nor is it perfectly rectangular. It's not a rectangle, grow it in your armpit or in
your breast or in your liver. It is a blob. And the blobs have, you know, think of a blob of
clay, you know, if you squashed it all over with your fingers and then you tried to take measurements.
Well, how would you measure that? What's with what angle you're looking at it? What angle you're holding
that blob of clay? There's a lot of room for discrepancy. So when you're looking at changes in size,
you're looking at changes that are relatively large. Also, even if it doubled in size, let's say
that would be a cause for concern. It wouldn't necessarily by itself be a cause for changing a
course of care or changing a course of treatment in everybody's case. Why? Because you don't just look
at one marker. So one marker would be one test, one lab, one CT scan, one, you know, you look at other
things. Why? Because other things can appear, can give you false impressions. It's the best way to
put it. What do you mean by that? Well, okay, when you're measuring a mass with an ultrasound
or CT scan or an MRI, the mass can appear larger by the way you measure it, by the dimensions
that you're using as far as the angle that you're looking at. There's so many variables that way.
But the mass can also appear larger if the mass is dyed. It might not be growth that's causing the
enlargement. Maybe it's a immune flare around the cancer that is a purine larger. So I personally had
patients that had a cancer mass in larger than they go into surgery. And it wasn't the cancer that
was enlarged. All the cells were dead. It was a immune response around it. That's possibility too.
That is always the case. But these are the things that you have to consider. That's why you never just
take one test and make your clinical decision. She would like to finish a question.
She would like me to get another opinion given all that I'm doing and my lack of progress.
She mentioned other alternative doctors, blah, blah, blah. Absolutely. You can get another opinion,
for sure. But this phrase concerns me all that I'm doing and my lack of progress.
So this is where non-cancer doctors and laypeople can make mistakes in thinking that you don't have
progress because the cancer isn't shrinking. So that would, I think, what she is defining as progress.
Why isn't the cancer shrinking? Okay. Remember, cancer is cells there in rapid replication. If it's no
longer rapidly replication, it rapidly replicated the rate of its increase in size is going to go down.
I think the larger the cancer is, if the cells are all in rapid replication, it's going to get larger
faster as time goes on. So if the course of one year, it's changed a couple of millimeters,
I would say that most of the cells are no longer cancerous. Why would you say lack of progress? To me,
that's, yeah, that's ignorance in understanding what cancer is. I might discourage you if you're
getting another opinion. Absolutely not. Go get another opinion. Go get other tests if that would make
you feel better. Do it MRI. Do a PET scan. Do other objective testing to give you some
sense that you're staying on the right way. If you want to look at other clinics, then absolutely
you should do that. I think, you know, as a believer, you should be praying about your decisions,
not making decisions based upon false security, but not making decisions based upon fear either. So look
at the results.